- Gustavo Petro devrait
devenir le prochain présid
de la Colombie, du moins,
s'il n'est pas assassiné,
dans un pays qui a une
longue tradition de eseseses
de candidats présidentiels.
Il a dû annuler des déplacements
à cause de menaces de groupes
narcoparamilitquququque tout
le monde a pris au sérieux.
Aussi, cet ancien député,
sénateur, maire de Bogota
a touteshahahahances
de gagner sauf si
les partisans du gouvernement
sortant parviennent à reporter,
voire annuler l'élection.
C'est ce sénateur, Rodrigo Lara,
qui a sonné l'alarme.
Les conservateurs
du président Duque sentent
la défaite; son gouvernement
est trop impopulaire.
RODRIGO LARA, sénateur
- La plupart des Colombiens
vivent dans l'informalité
et ils ont pas dépensé
un sou dans ces populations,
ce qui fait que le choc
a été très brutal.
- Et, en pleine crise
d'une COVID mal gérée,
le président Ivan Duque
lance une réforme fiscale
avec une TVA sur
les produits alimentaires.
- Ces produits alime
qui sont très sensibles dans
une population très pauvre
ou dans l'informalité,
a fait que le... a provoqué
une explosion, une crise
sociale d'une dimension
que nous n'avions pas vécue
depuis 1948 et ce qui a été
accompagné, bien sûr, tout
de suite par lsesesesesement
des démons de notre société.
- Federico Gutierrez, surnommé
Fico, tente de se distancer
du gouvernement sortant.
Cet ancien maire de Medellin
veut lutter contre
l'insécurité et la pauvreté.
"Il y a 20 millions
de Colombiens en situation
de pauvreté, presque
40 % de la population."
Ingrid Betancourt, la Franco-
Colombienne, ex-otage des FARC,
décidément très impopulaireenené
à sa candidature pour
soutenir Rodolfo Fernandez.
Ce milliardaire populiste
pourrait jouer le trouble-fête
pour les deux candidats en tête.
Ils veulent la paix,
la réconciliation et
la fondation d'un nouveau pays.
"Ce pays, dit-elle,
nous allons le faire ensemble."
La paix a été faite avec
la guérilla des FARC il y a
six ans, mais elle ne règne pas.
- Les problèmes de base restent,
restent. Donc, vous avez
des zones entières du pays
sans État. Vous avez
des véritables archipels humains
qui sont un peu semés
un peu partout dans le pays,
qui n'ont pas d'accès auxrvrvrÉ.
- Ces zones sont encore
et toujours sous emprise
des groupes armés, ex-FARC, ELN,
paramilitaires, narcos du
clan du golfe, qui terrorisent
encore des régions entières.
Ces régions vont voter
pour le candidat
de gauche Gustavo Petro.
"Il faut mettre un terme
aux violences permanentes
et à une guerre sans fin
où des générations
ont répandu leur sang."
Reste à savoir à quel point
les grandes villes du pays
ont le même désir de paix.
L'élection d'un prés
de gauche en Colombie serait
une première dans l'histoire
du pays. Au premier tour?
Plus probablement au second,
le 19 juin
beaucoup d'inconnues.
Des sondages peu fiables
et aussi une abstention
généralement très élevée ici,
vevevevevevevevevent donner
lieu à bien des surprises.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Bogot